so I want to get this back to this
grass-fed thing because I said I just
watched Food Inc and I'm big on the
grass-fed meat right now for for many
reasons health reasons it's better for
the environment all kinds of stuff
that's what cows we're supposed to eat
so it's better for the cows etc etc so
the Scots company which created modified
Roundup Ready Kentucky bluegrass is
going to be doing field trials with this
stuff and we've got a quote from GMO
free on why this is bad so they're
saying that GMO Roundup Ready grass will
result in a further increase in the use
of Roundup which will contaminate our
groundwater and drinking water imagine
your children and pets frolicking around
in a sea of herbicidal poison because of
inevitable contamination the grass is
likely to be eaten by grass grass
grazing animals so basically what
they're saying is that this company is
going to make this grass it's the grass
is going to be more resistant to the
chemicals so they're gonna need more
chemicals and that chemical stuff is
just gonna get all over the place did I
basically get that yeah I mean again
it's like with the word chemical is like
so insane to me I recently did a podcast
on top my podcast talk nerdy with a with
a doctor named Kevin falta who is an
agriculture scientist at the University
of Florida and he studies transgenes he
works of strawberries by the way no GMO
strawberries did you guys know that
there's actually not that many GMO crops
on the market no such thing as a GMO
strawberry or tomato really but it might
mistaken all bananas or GMO I'm not sure
if that's true but like all corn corn
corn or shorten week everything's
growing everything we're wearing in this
table everything is quite so anyway and
so I agree with you I like the idea of
grass-fed meat I also like the idea of
having a better grass right so a bit of
risk that needs less water I mean there
are reasons and there's reasons that we
use roundup Roundup Ready crops are able
to not die when you use this herbicide
that kills the things that can infect
the crop that kills the things that can
take over the crop yield yeah you spray
the crop with Roundup the crop lives
everything else dies so you have a good
yield of that crop now there's not much
evidence out there to support these
claims either that like a like a fate
something like a fate I can never
you remember that like the face yeah the
main ingredient in roundup yeah it is
going to have any sort of detriment to
groundwater any sort of content it's
specifically these things often the
herbicides and the pesticides that that
GM crops are kind of made to withstand
the herbicides and pesticides have been
tested say if it's not DDT these are
things that we use in every large
agricultural complex they're big big
farms they're constantly sprayed with
these things and you only need a very
small amount of them because they're
Roundup Ready if they weren't Roundup
Ready we'd have to use massive amounts
of herbicides because these are Roundup
Ready crops we use a tiny amount of
roundup and kill off anything that the
crop is not resistant to okay so that's
exactly obviously why I wanted to bring
this up with you to clear up some of the
science so you as the newsperson of this
and this goes to one of the topics we
were talking about earlier about Ebola
and the hysteria and all this there's so
much hysteria related to GMOs which is
why I think when we started this you
were ready to pounce immediately because
it's so polarizing for some reason I can
already see what's gonna happen in the
comment section here so how do we get
some of this across I think we kind of
cleaned it up here but it's not this is
our food source is so important and yet
it's never talked about I think what's
most important is awareness and that
that's where we're really failing so we
at the moment we can't even we don't
even have like rules or regulations
robust regulations across the country
that tell us what's in our food and
what's not in our food and that I think
is where we can make a huge impact it's
not an eliminating GMOs or eliminating
such-and-such chemical it's about
understanding GMOs understanding
chemicals and then informing the
consumer when they're in our products
yeah I completely agree with that I
think that you know with the labeling
initiatives whether it's GMO or not we
need to go significantly further we need
to talk about how far does our food
travel to get to our plate what other
kinds of ingredients are put in our food
that are able to be veiled under the the
label artificial or natural ingredients
so now these Agri or these food
companies don't even have to tell us
what they're putting in there's a lot of
other things I do what I can the
labeling get too crazy also because
there's so many labels and you're never
sure what is at
natural thing that is regulated right
now that's that's part of why it's so
crazy and and I just want to make one
last point because it was glaringly
obvious me some of the the text that you
were reading on that screen there's one
thing about there's never been a GM crop
that's been proven to improve yield or
improve health or safety it said
something along those lines which is
also a bold-faced lie more corn like it
or not
well yes but also let's let's kind of
travel back in time very quickly to the
1970s when scientists developed Golden
Rice which produced more beta-carotene
it produced more of vitamin that
individuals in impoverished nations
didn't have access to and the idea was
if we plant this rice which is a staple
crop in these nations instead of the
nutritionally kind of vacant rice that
they're eating right now we're going to
see massive improvements in health and
human safety and Greenpeace which is an
organization that I typically back
Greenpeace was so up in arms about this
that they essentially stopped the Golden
Rice program and there have been lots of
studies to show that millions of lives
weren't saved that could have been
because we did have a viable option a
viable GM crop that could have saved
lives and the red tape got in the way
yeah all right so that's a perfect segue
to my final thought on this which is we
talked about the big business end of its
all the time so we can't talk about GMOs
without talking about Monsanto so just
literally in like a minute is this just
an so Monsanto basically they're forcing
if I understand this correctly they
basically force farmers to use they've
copyrighted because the supreme court
allowed them to do it
they've crappie righted these crops and
they're forcing farmers to use them and
you force somebody to buy your product
they literally have inspectors that go
around to make sure that their seeds
aren't being used that others if you
purchased it if you're somebody who
purchases a monsanto seed and plants it
you have you can plant it if you're
somebody who didn't buy their seeds and
you're not allowed to plant their seeds
that's the way it works if you if you
sell a product and you can't steal the
seed no I just think that also the
lawsuit side of things is really
overblown and a lot of times if you
really dig into the research
the only lawsuits that have actually
made it to court and where P where
Monsanto has actually had a win are
places where they were able to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that farmers
were using Monsanto crops without
purchasing them right so in the farmers
defense they some have argued that you
know what I didn't want to use this crop
but hello like seeds fly patrons it's
the environment we can't contain
everything and now that the seed and now
that the seed has reached my fields its
overtaken all my other states and I'm
forcing there's not even a lawsuit
that's that's actually come to fruition
that shows that so it's yes it's you
hear it you hear the chatter about it
but nobody's actually been prosecuted
for that yeah it just seems kind of
messy and from the way I get it is sort
of I would always side I guess with the
farmer that's that it he's on the land
sort of controlling most farmers that
use GM crops and use Monsanto crops
purchase them because they work and they
purchase them because it's it's cheap
and they're able to make a big yield
because of it they're not being forced
to buy these crops they can buy other
seeds they choose to buy Monsanto seeds
yeah all right well I have a feeling
we're gonna have a big yield in the
comment section bring up so seriously
let us know we'll do this again in a
couple weeks I want to keep the
discussion going on this stuff because
that's how important I think the the
food source conversation is and and the
whole thing